[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily a
federal judge now ruling a defamation
lawsuit against three of trump's allies
over false election fraud claims can
move forward and horrific details in the
murders of two children allegedly at the
hands of their father the fbi revealing
q anon conspiracies so-called serpent
dna and a spear gun plus the ex-wife of
a murdered former nba player withdraws
her request to throw out her guilty plea
her accused accomplished to loren's
rights murder prepares for trial when
you get ready to commit a crime be ready
for your time and i am here
to plead for the life of stephen wickens
defense attorneys for a convicted cop
killer make their case one final time to
spare him from the death penalty plus
why robert durst is now admitting to
lying to police about the disappearance
of his first wife it never dawned on me
that anything could happen to her law
and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin a federal judge is handing
dominion voting system a procedural win
the defamation lawsuit against three of
former president trump's allies can move
forward
rudy giuliani sydney powell and my
pillow ceo mike lindell have lost their
bids to dismiss billion dollar lawsuits
accusing them of defaming voting
equipment company dominion over their
false presidential election fraud claims
in a 44-page opinion a federal judge
said there is no blanket immunity for
statements that are political in nature
but it is simply not the law that
provable false statements cannot be
actionable if made in the context of an
election this is not a close call the
judge said the suits will move forward
towards trial dominion also filed
billion-dollar lawsuits against newsmax
and one america news network
terry this federal judge did not hold
back in their decision was this the
result you expected and what's next for
these three
you know it was the result i expected i
did think the suit was going to proceed
forward but i didn't expect the judge to
be so adamant about the decision the
proof however brian is very very strong
i mean for a defamation case you have to
show that there was a false statement we
have that the big lie you have to say
that it was intentional or even
negligent and we have that the
publication of that and damages and i
think that dominion will be able to
prove all that and that's why the judge
decided it'll go forward as far as
what's next the complaint will be filed
the defendants will then do their
answers of course and i do anticipate a
lot of discovery with this case so i
think it's going to be quite some time
until we see the actual trial yeah this
is actually interesting situation
because a lot of discovery is out there
in the public and open we saw a lot of
these statements that the judge is
agreeing
we're false and provably false as they
put it thank you very much terry
now to a disturbing story of a
california father allegedly admitting to
killing his children over so-called
serpent dna and q on conspiracy theories
fbi agents say matthew coleman uses
speargun to murder his two kids in
mexico earlier this month according to a
criminal complaint coleman took his 10
month old daughter and two-year-old son
from their california home on august 7.
two days later coleman allegedly
confessed to using a fishing spear to
pierce them in the heart because he
believed his children were going to grow
into monsters so he had to kill them
coleman reportedly said he was
enlightened by q anon and illuminati
conspiracy theories and was receiving
visions and signs revealing his wife
possessed serpent dna and had passed it
on to his children coleman was arrested
at the border and is facing charges of
foreign murder of u.s nationals
now to tennessee where the ex-wife of a
former nba player who's serving time for
his murder is back in court as another
man gets a trial date for the killing
law and crimes angenette levy is here
with the latest on lorenzen wright
murder case and jeanette
brian lorenzen-wright was murdered in
memphis tennessee in 2010 his ex-wife is
serving a 30-year sentence and another
man is getting ready to go on trial
shira wright back in a tennessee
courtroom this week she pleaded guilty
in 2019 to facilitating the murder of
her ex-husband lorenzen wright she had
filed a petition asking the court for
relief claiming her defense attorney was
ineffective and her confession coerced
but now she says she's changed her mind
under tennessee law if you tell the
court the judge would draw this petition
i no longer want to go forward on this
petition you can never refile this
petition do you understand that now yes
sir judge lee coffey questioned her
about whether she'd been pressured to
withdraw the petition
and is this your decision about it yes
it is wright's change of heart about her
plea deal frustrated lorenzen wright's
mother lorenzon played in the nba for 13
years for a number of teams including
the memphis grizzlies
but i told all of my grandkids from day
one whoever killed your daddy they're
going down because i'm not gonna let the
rest of the day i die as wright goes
back to prison billy ray turner who's
also charged with killing lorenzen
wright learns his trial will begin in
january 2022
i want that
because i want them to hear the error
beginning to the end
shira wright is eligible for parole in
2026 that's five years from now lorenzen
wright's mother believes that a 1
million life insurance policy for her
son's children was the motive for the
murder brian
thanks ange joining us today is criminal
defense attorney gigi gonzalez gigi with
right looking at parole in 2026 do you
think she would testify against billy
ray turner to help her chances of early
release
there's a really good possibility we're
gonna see wright testify against turner
if her testimony helps secure a
conviction against him then that's gonna
go really well for her when they're
deciding on whether or not to release
her uh when her pro comes around in
2026. yeah as we know i think in most
states and often times the parolee
doesn't get released the first time this
would definitely put her in a good light
to maybe even get it in the first
release or even the second and jeanette
what's the connection between sheba
wright and billy ray turner
well billy ray turner was a landscaper
and a deacon at a baptist church and
apparently shira wright attended that
church and that's how they knew one
another and somehow became involved in
this scheme together
all right and do you what do you think
about this potential for shira to
testify do you think that might
sweeten the pot for her come 2026 for
parole or do you think we won't hear
from her ever again anjanet
you know i think we'll have to to wait
and see what happens of course um it
would be interesting if she did because
if she's already admitted guilt she's
pleaded guilty to this so her testimony
could end up being a slam dunk for the
prosecution or make the case a slam dunk
for the prosecution should she take the
stand yeah the only thing i can think
now is whether or not the prosecution
will give her that opportunity they
might have a strong enough case without
her so of course like angenette says we
just gotta wait and see
thank you
still ahead on law and crime daily
robert durst takes a stand in his own
defense how he changed his mind on what
happened the last time he saw his wife
but first what awaits a convicted cop
killer as the jury decides his fate why
his death throw jail tattoos might
influence their vote ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live one
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
now to tennessee and why the timeline
for when a convicted cop killer got
several shocking tattoos is so important
to the defense
hellbound show no mercy and crush your
enemies are just some of the tattoos
that stephen wiggins has on his body a
jury is now deciding whether wiggins
should face the death penalty or spend
the rest of his life in prison for the
murder of sergeant daniel baker the
state called the deputy who transports
wiggins to court he testified that
wiggins got these tattoos while in
custody this was later proved to be
false wiggins already had the show no
mercy tattoo but did get a tattoo in
jail that says death row
can you describe for us what the wording
at the bottom of the tattoo says
it says crush your enemies show no mercy
and is that tattoo
new and when i say new did it occur
after he was arrested on this homicide
case
yes and it occurred sometime while he
was being held in the robertson county
jail yes
deputy calhoun testified yesterday
that
he had witnessed mr wiggins back prior
to him entering
custody in this case
and that the test the back tattoo that
said crush your enemies show no mercy
was not there
since that time and overnight
we've come across information to show
that that testimony by detective calhoun
or deputy calhoun rather was false
in fact that
there's pictures noting that that tattoo
was in existence
um on monday october 27th 2014.
now to closing arguments where is the
defense's last chance to plead with the
jury to save wigan's life
no one's telling you i'm not here to
tell you these things to get you to
forgive stephen wiggins
you couldn't you wouldn't
and i'm not asking you to
that would be a bridge too far
what i'm asking you to do
what he said he was willing to do what
you saw in the proof
is put him in a box
for the rest of his life
after testimony by the defense showed
wiggins grew up with an abusive father
prosecutors refocused the jury on who
this case is actually about
stephen wiggins
never had a chance
no
he had lots of chances
he had lots of chances to make the moral
decision and he had the ability
capability of making the moral decision
the only person in this case never had a
chance
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney g.j gonzalez and terry austin
tell you the prosecution pointed out
that wiggins got a tattoo saying death
row while in jail could this be a sign
of guilt or a recognition of what he's
facing
brian i think it's a sign of guilt and i
think it's a recognition of what he very
well could be facing because the
prosecution did a great job in that last
rebuttal statement and as we heard the
officer who testified about the tattoos
testified wrong he wasn't correct on all
of them and clearly one of the tattoos
the one that said crush your enemy show
no mercy that was there before but the
other tattoos were there after
defendant was in prison and so you know
what the defense tried to argue was that
it was a poor decision and that you know
we make these poor decisions but i
thought the prosecution did a much
better job saying that that tattoo the
one where he's talking about you know
making sure that you know he's staying
in prison he's going to jail these these
are definitely you know
indications of guilt as far as i'm
concerned so i think the tattoos are
going against the defendant i can see
that point of view as well and i can
already hear my mother saying see brian
this is why you shouldn't have got a
tattoo if you get arrested this will
happen to you so be careful the tattoos
you get
did the prosecution's rebuttal push this
case towards an execution
you know i definitely think it got him
really close to it you know
unfortunately for better for worse
tattoos send a message to to the world
right even before you get to say
anything and the jurors are going to see
that and they're deciding on whether or
not to impose a life sentence or send
this man to to death row for the brutal
murder of a cop and he's getting tattoos
that say hell bound and death row and
show no mercy it's definitely not gonna
help the jurors sympathize with him
whatsoever
but of course as we've said it only
takes one and we're not quite sure what
that verdict will be maybe one person is
just an absolute hold out and they said
no matter what i will not go with the
death penalty or
all these signs and these tattoos are
pointing to the execution of stephen
wiggins well of course keep you updated
as that continues coming up on law and
crime daily fact or fiction robert durst
takes a stand in his own defense for the
murder of susan berman his explanation
for his lies to law enforcement next
[Music]
welcome back captivating testimony of
robert durst on the stand is continuing
for a third day the real estate air is
now admitting to lying to investigators
about the disappearance of his first
wife in 1982.
robert durst is on trial for the
december 2000 murder of his best friend
susan berman but durst is also accused
of killing his first wife kathy two
decades earlier prosecutors say durst
killed berman to stop her from coming
forward with information about kathy's
presumed murder durst maintains his
innocence for both deaths for years
durst has said kathy left her home in
south salem in new york on january 31st
1982 and got on a train headed for the
city
did you actually see her get on the
train
well everybody's asked me that question
and i've changed my mind probably a
dozen times
she was standing on the platform
with half a dozen people
the train pulled into the platform
the doors open
the people got on the train
the doors closed
and the train left
now did i actually
see
kathy
walk through the doors
onto the train
and the answer is i don't know
but there is no no place else to go
on the stand durst admitted to lying to
a new york city police detective about
speaking to kathy the following morning
you told
detective strzok that you had gone to
the mayor's house to have a drink that's
what i told them was that true
no why did you tell him that
it seemed like he wanted me to tell him
that i had done stuff
after taking kathy to the train i sort
of told him what i felt like he wanted
to hear did you call kathy later that
night
no
did you tell detective strzok that you
had i did
i told detective stroke
that i had telephoned cassie had a
riverside drive apartment
and she was watching the news
that wasn't true that was a lie
why did you tell that lie
because i wanted to convince him
that kathy had gotten back to every side
drive
durst says he called susan berman a few
days later to say that he was concerned
kathy was missing several days of school
never dawned on me
that anything could happen to her
it was more like what had cassie done to
cathy
and when you say what had cathy done to
kathy what do you mean your concern was
the cocaine
and the alcohol
i was still
not imagining
that something could happen to kathy
was not imagining
that the last time i would see her
was when she stepped on onto the train
i was imagining
that she was out someplace
having fun
when we come back what happened when
durst reported kathy is missing is his
story adding up you decide after the
break
back now to the trial of robert durst
where the real estate heir is on the
stand denying he murdered his best
friend or his first wife durst says he
reported kathy is missing in 1982 but
please didn't take it seriously
i'm a receptionist
and i asked
how do i go about
reporting a missing person
and the lady said
who's missing
and i said kathy durst
my wife
a lady
had a sense of humor
she said to me
with a little bit of a giggle
have you checked with your wife's
boyfriend
how did you take that
i said my wife does not have a boyfriend
she said
have you checked
with all your wife's boyfriends
the story of the wife disappearing from
the wealthy family was quickly picked up
by the tabloids durst says he needed to
bring in his best friend susan berman to
be his spokesperson
she offered
and did you take her up on the offer
i said i would talk i would think about
it i would get past her that's monday
evening right
right when did you next meet with or
talk with your father or anybody in the
durst organization well i spoke to dad
and douglas every day
leonard mandela once
and dad said he'd had up a meeting
for thursday afternoon
with nix caparra
and nick scapatta's investigator
were you keep were the detectives
keeping you abreast or informed of what
was going on with the investigation
i heard nothing from what he had first
so
tuesday wednesday
thursday before the meeting had you
heard anything from the investigators
then
no
was your state of mind then
i was upset
gigi durst's memory does not seem to be
failing in here what did you think of
his explanation of durs reporting kathy
was missing
i think it is such a strange explanation
and especially how he goes on to say
that he's changed his mind a dozen times
you know here he's taking the stand
essentially testifying for his life and
he goes on to say that he lies to cops
and he lies to convince him of stories i
really don't know how this testimony is
going to go well with the jurors here
all right so let's play a little devil's
advocate gigi sometimes uh criminal
defendants will admit to some things and
and deny other things to try to show a
little bit of credibility uh once a
great miami criminal defense attorney
said it's like showing that your hands
are dirty but not bloody could durst be
doing that here
yeah possibly because if you're up front
about hey look listen i don't remember
this particular lie that i told in 1980
but the fact that i'm being honest with
you today just goes to show how
forthright i am the problem is he's got
so many similar types of stories and
lies that it's really hard to believe
that it could just be that he's got
dirty hands here
yeah you see 20 lies in one truth it's
kind of hard to believe which one's
which i think the jury is probably
seeing through that and that brings us
to you terry i'm sure lewin already has
a billion questions on cross ready to go
but do you see any inconsistencies in
dursa's testimony that lewin will likely
attack
that's an excellent question and yes
there are a billion questions i'm sure
lewin is going to go after durst but i
think he's going to start by the
beginning he's going to talk about the
relationship that durst had with his
family members and the fact that his own
siblings were afraid of him he's going
to talk about the fact that he didn't
have a good relationship with kathy
durst even though he tried to portray
the fact that they had a medium
relationship it really wasn't it was
really a terrible relationship as many
of kathy's friends reported i think he's
also going to question durst about all
of his inconsistent statements to
detective strzok and his inconsistent
statements
primarily about that cadaver note he's
not going to leave that out and you know
finally i think he's going to talk about
chopping up
black's body because that's true so he's
got a lot to talk about on
cross-examination he's got a lot to talk
about and i don't think he'll avoid any
of those topics thank you for joining us
here at law on crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you